well joining me now is the deputy
director of research at cure parkinson's
dr
simon stop dr stop thank you very much
for being with us this isn't a cure but
how significant a step is it
i think it's an extremely significant
step uh understanding the basic biology
of what is happening with proteins
involved with parkinson's like
alpha-synuclein
helps us to better understand how we
could be
treating the condition and slowing
stopping or
reversing it
yeah so this is a protein that was first
discovered what 30 years ago or so it's
been much studied but where does this
research take us forward
it has important implications for
ongoing clinical trials
um it has been 30 years since alpha
nuclean was well
25 years actually since alpha
syndication was first discovered
but um the we have clinical trials
ongoing at the moment
that are targeting this uh protein um
so this new research will have important
implications for those clinical trials
that are ongoing
what hopes do you have about what it
could potentially
lead to um
tremendous hopes alison nuclean is um
generally seen as a fundamental player
within the pathology of parkinson's
and potentially playing a key role in
the progression of it
and so if we can um have a better
understanding
of what this protein does generally in
the in the brain but also within the
context of parkinson's
then that helps us certainly with
regards to finding
curative therapies for this condition
yeah in terms of of therapies what is
existing at the moment what is available
to those who are suffering from it
but currently there are no curative
condition
therapies for parkinson's everything
that is
currently used in the clinic is what we
call symptomatic treatments
they uh cover up the symptoms and let
people
go about their daily lives providing
great um
quality of life but gradually underneath
the surface
the disease is still progressing and so
what we're looking for are what we call
disease modifying
therapies that will slow stop or reverse
the condition
and um they they're
currently there as i said before there
are currently no therapies of that
nature
there are however a lot of clinical
trials ongoing
there are groups like cure parkinson's
michael j fox
parkinson's uk and we're all working
very hard very collaboratively
to bring disease modifying therapies to
the clinic for parkinson's
and currently there are a lot of trials
ongoing we'll be hearing a lot of
um clinical trial results this year and
they will also be seeing their start
hopefully covered willing
the start of more disease modifying
therapies as well
it is the it is the fastest growing
neurological
condition in the world you described
there some of the clinical trials going
on i wonder
whether given that context given the
fact 10 million people
suffering from parkinson's disease does
it get enough government funding enough
international attention
uh no definitely not and given given
that it is
growing but at a fast rate as opposed to
conditions like alzheimer's which are
simply
progressing with the aging population
given that parkinson's is
um accelerating in growth
we can foresee future um
being a future burden for society and
um it certainly needs a lot more
attention and a lot more focus
and this is what basic research like um
what is being presented today
is certainly helping yeah i mean we
talked about some of the the
high-profile
people living with parkinson's disease
ozzy osbourne
uh billy colley connolly michael j
fox i mean michael j fox was 29 when he
was
diagnosed we tend to think of this as a
condition that affects those
as they grow older but michael j
fox showing that this isn't that isn't
always the case
no typically one in every 20 cases is
diagnosed under the age of 40.
so it's one of the great misnomers of
parkinson's everybody thinks of it as
the condition of the aged but it still
affects a lot of
um individuals at a very young age
there's generally
some genetic risks risk factors involved
with the younger
onset forms of the condition and um
this uh this these identification of
these genetic risk factors has helped us
to better understand the biology of
parkinson's for example this protein
that we're talking about today
uh there's genetic risk factors involved
with with that protein
and that's what led us to this protein
in the first place and the
better understanding of the biology of
these risk factors is helping us to
design
uh therapies that could potentially slow
stop or reverse parkinson's in the
future
and make a huge difference to all of
those suffering from it dr simon stop
thank you very much